[Attention ! Cette présentation contient du langage explicite.]
Ceci est le premier et unique transparent
que j’ai présenté depuis 15 ans à mes 6 500 étudiants.
Je ne crois pas qu’on peut bâtir une organisation multimilliardaire
sans savoir précisément à quel instinct, à quel organe, on veut faire appel.
Notre espèce a besoin d'une entité surnaturelle.
Notre cerveau nous distingue des autres espèces.
Il est assez puissant pour poser des questions très complexes,
mais n'a hélas pas la capacité d'y trouver des réponses.
On a besoin d'une présence surnaturelle
vers laquelle nous tourner et prier pour trouver des réponses.
Qu’est-ce que la prière ?
C’est l’envoi d’une demande à travers l’univers,
en espérant une sorte d’intervention divine --
pas besoin de comprendre ce qu'il se passe --
de la part d’une entité surnaturelle omnipotente
qui nous confère l’autorité d’imposer la bonne réponse.
« Mon enfant va-t-il guérir ? »
Vous avez votre planète de choses,
vous avez votre planète de travail,
vous avez votre planète d’amis.
Si vous avez des enfants,
vous savez que dès qu’une chose tourne au vinaigre,
votre monde s'effondre,
dans cet univers dont vos enfants sont le soleil.
« Mon enfant va-t-il guérir ? »
« Symptômes et traitements de la toux » dans la barre de recherche de Google.
Un sixième des recherches sur Google n’ont jamais été posées
dans l’histoire de l’humanité.
Quel prêtre, professeur, rabbin, savant, mentor ou patron est assez crédible
pour qu'on lui pose une question qui n’a jamais été posée,
même si ce n'est qu'une sur 6 ?
Google est le Dieu de l’homme moderne.
Associez votre visage et votre nom sur toutes vos recherches Google,
et vous réaliserez que vous faites plus confiance à Google
qu'à n’importe quelle autre entité.
(Rires)
Descendons vers le buste.
Une autre chose merveilleuse au sujet de notre espèce
n'est pas uniquement son besoin d'amour, mais aussi celui d’aimer les autres.
Les enfants mal nourris, mais recevant beaucoup d’affection,
réussissent mieux que les enfants bien nourris recevant peu d’affection.
Toutefois, le meilleur indice de votre éventuelle réussite
pour faire partie des gagnants de la croissance démographique --
les centenaires, les personnes qui vivent à trois chiffres --
il y a trois signes.
Dans l’ordre croissant : vos gènes, mais c'est moins important qu'on ne le croit.
Vous pouvez continuer à maltraiter votre corps et dire :
« Oh, Oncle Joe a vécu jusqu’à 95 ans, les dés sont jetés. »
Ne vous y fiez pas.
Numéro deux, le mode vie.
Évitez de fumer, l’obésité, passez des examens préventifs.
Vous échapperez à deux tiers des cancers précoces
et aux maladies cardiovasculaires.
L’indicateur ultime que vous vivrez au-delà de 100 ans :
combien de personnes aimez-vous ?
Prendre soin des autres, c'est le monitoring --
la caméra de surveillance basse résolution dans le cerveau --
qui décide si on fait une bonne action.
Facebook exploite notre besoin instinctif d’être aimé,
et aussi d’aimer les autres,
surtout via des photos qui créent de l’empathie,
catalysent, et renforcent nos relations.
Continuons notre voyage le long du torse.
Amazon est notre intestin de consommation.
L'instinct d'insatisfaction est profondément ancré en nous.
La conséquence des carences, c'est la famine et la malnutrition.
Ouvrez vos armoires et vos placards
vous avez 10 à 100 fois plus que ce dont vous avez besoin.
Pourquoi ?
Parce que la conséquence de « pas assez » est bien plus pénible
que celle du « beaucoup trop ».
Du coup, « plus pour moins cher » est une stratégie commerciale toujours gagnante.
C’est la stratégie de la Chine,
c’est la stratégie de Walmart,
et c’est la stratégie de l'entreprise la plus prospère au monde :
Amazon.
Vous obtenez plus pour moins dans votre intestin.
Vous digérez et transmettez ça à votre propre système de consommation.
Continuons plus bas,
une fois que l'on sait qu'on va survivre, l’instinct primaire,
on peut passer au deuxième instinct le plus puissant,
qui est de répandre et sélectionner la graine la plus forte, intelligente
et rapide aux quatre coins du monde,
ou de choisir la meilleure graine.
Ceci n’est pas une montre ;
en cinq ans, je ne l’ai jamais remontée.
C’est ma tentative futile de dire aux gens :
« Si tu t'accouples avec moi, tes enfants ont plus de chance de survivre
qu'avec quelqu’un qui porte une Swatch. »
(Rires)
La clé des affaires, c’est exploiter des organes irrationnels.
Irrationnel, pour l'université d'Harvard et l'école de commerce de New York,
est le terme qui désigne les profits juteux et la valeur actionnariale.
« Pâte à tartiner hypercalorique pour vos enfants ».
Non ?
Vous aimez votre maman maniaque.
Pourquoi elle achète du Nutella ? Elle aime plus ses enfants.
L'algorithme de création de valeur actionnariale depuis la 2ème guerre
à l’avènement de Google,
était de choisir un produit moyen et d'en appeler au cœur.
Vous êtes une meilleure mère, personne, ou patriote
si vous achetez ce savon moyen, au lieu de cet autre savon moyen.
Aujourd’hui, l’algorithme ultime des actionnaires n’est pas la technologie,
regardez le Forbes 400.
Oubliez la richesse par héritage et la finance.
La 1e source de création de richesse est :
plaire à vos organes reproducteurs.
Les Lauders ; l’homme le plus riche d’Europe : LVMH.
En deuxième et troisième positions : H&M et Inditex.
On veut viser les organes les plus irrationnels pour les dividendes.
Le résultat est que ces quatre entreprises : Apple, Amazon,
Facebook et Google, ont désarticulé qui nous sommes.
Dieu, l’amour, la consommation, le sexe.
Le poids relatif que vous accordez à chaque élément fait de vous qui vous êtes.
Ils compilent qui nous sommes et le destinent aux entreprises.
À la fin de la Grande Récession,
la valeur boursière de ces entreprises était équivalente
au PIB du Niger.
Maintenant, c’est l’équivalent du PIB de l’Inde,
Après avoir brûlé la priorité à la Russie et au Canada en 2013 et 14.
Il n’y a que cinq pays
qui ont un PIB supérieur à la valeur boursière combinée
de ces quatre entreprises.
Toutefois, le vent semble tourner.
Il y a un an, nos conversations tournaient autour du côté messianique
de tel ou tel dirigeant.
Qui serait candidat à la présidence ?
La situation a changé et tout ce qu’ils font nous dérange.
Ça nous déplait s’ils fuient le fisc.
Walmart, depuis la Grande Récession, a payé 64 milliards de dollars
en impôt des sociétés.
Amazon a payé 1,4 milliard.
Comment paie-t-on nos pompiers, nos soldats, ou nos travailleurs sociaux
si les sociétés les plus florissantes ne contribuent équitablement ?
C'est simple.
Cela veut dire que les entreprises moins florissantes doivent payer plus.
Alexa, est-ce une bonne chose ?
Et ce en dépit du fait --
(Rires)
en dépit du fait
que la capitalisation d’Amazon a crû l’équivalent de celle de Walmart
ces 19 derniers mois.
La faute à qui ? À nous.
Nous élisons des législateurs sans les tripes nécessaires
pour vraiment poursuivre ces entreprises.
Facebook ment aux législateurs européens
en disant : « Ça sera impossible de partager les données
entre notre plate-forme et celle de WhatsApp, que nous souhaitons acquérir.
Approuvez donc la fusion. »
Ils ont approuvé la fusion et puis : Alerte arnaque ! Ils ont compris.
L’Europe déclare alors : « On nous a menti.
Nous vous imposons une amende de 120 milliards de dollars. »
Environ 0,6% du prix d’acquisition, 19 milliards de dollars.
Si Mark Zuckerberg avait pu contracter une police d’assurance
pour couvrir les 0,6% de cette acquisition,
ne l’aurait-il pas fait ?
Un comportement anti-concurrentiel.
L'amende de 2,5 milliards de dollars représente
3 % de la trésorerie de Google sur son bilan comptable.
On dit à ces entreprises : « La façon la plus intelligente de créer
de l’intérêt pour les actionnaires,
c’est de mentir et de tricher. »
On délivre des amendes de stationnement à 25 centimes
sur un horodateur qui coûte 100 dollars de l’heure.
Mentir est plus malin.
Destruction des emplois !
Amazon a besoin d’une personne contre deux chez Macy.
Si Amazon développe ses affaires de 20 milliards cette année, et il le fera,
on perdra 53 000 caissières et agents.
Rien de surprenant ;
cela arrive partout dans notre économie.
Mais on n'avait jamais vu des sociétés si douées.
Ça remplirait le stade des Yankees.
C’est pire dans les médias.
Si Facebook et Google se développent de 22 milliards cette année,
et ils les atteindront,
nous perdrons presque 150 000 directeurs de création,
planificateurs et rédacteurs.
Nous pourrons remplir 2,5 stades des Yankees
et dire : « Vous êtes au chômage, merci Amazon. »
Aujourd'hui, on obtient la plupart des infos sur les médias sociaux
et la majorité des informations provenant des médias sont...
fausses.
(Rires)
Je ne suis pas autorisé à parler politique et à tenir des propos injurieux
ou à parler de religion en cours.
Je ne peux donc assurément pas dire :
« Zuckerberg, c'est la pute de Poutine ».
Je ne suis vraiment pas autorisé à dire ça.
(Rires)
Leur défense :
« Facebook n’est pas un média mais une entreprise de technologie. »
Vous créez du contenu,
vous payez des ligues sportives pour vous donner du contenu,
vous affichez de la publicité, boum ! Vous êtes un média.
Ces derniers jours,
Sheryl Sandberg a répété ce mensonge : « On n'est pas un média. »
Facebook a accueilli les bras ouverts les marges bénéficiaires des célébrités
et l’influence d'une société de médias
mais semble toujours allergique aux responsabilités
associées aux sociétés de médias.
Prenez McDonald’s par exemple.
On découvre que 80% de leur bœuf n’en est pas.
Ça nous transmet l'encéphalite,
et on prend des décisions terribles.
Alors on dit : « McDonald’s, Tu nous emmerdes ! »
Et ils répondent : « On se calme ! Un moment !
Nous ne proposons pas de la restauration rapide,
nous sommes une plateforme de restauration rapide. »
(Rires)
Ces sociétés et dirigeants se drapent
dans un voile irisé aux couleurs de l'arc-en-ciel, façon Bisounours,
pour créer une illusion de leur comportement quotidien,
en fait plus proche de la progéniture de Dark Vador et Ayn Rand.
Pourquoi ? Car on nous trouve, nous, les progressistes, sympas mais faibles.
Si Sheryl Sandberg avait écrit un livre sur le droit de porter des armes
ou sur le mouvement pro-vie,
emmèneraient-ils Sheryl jusqu’à Cannes en jet privé ?
Non.
Je ne doute pas de leurs valeurs progressistes
mais elles sont soumises au cours de l'action
car les progressistes sont vus faibles.
Ils sont si sympathiques, rappelez-vous Microsoft !
Ils ne paraissaient pas aussi sympathiques,
et les législateurs s’y sont intéressés plus tôt.
Leurs contemporains n'oseront jamais intervenir auprès de ces belles gens.
Je dois prendre un avion ce soir
et il y aura ce gars, de la sécurité, Roy, qui va m'agresser.
Si on me suspecte de conduite en état d’ivresse en rentrant à la maison,
on pourra m'obliger à faire une prise de sang.
Mais attendez ! Ils ne peuvent pas regarder mon iPhone.
Ça, c’est sacré.
C’est notre nouveaux crucifix.
Ça ne devrait pas être iPhone X,
mais « l’iPhone Crucifix ».
On a notre religion, c’est Apple.
Steve Jobs est notre Messie
et on a décidé que ceci était plus sacré que notre corps, notre maison
ou que notre ordinateur.
On est devenu totalement incontrôlable
dans notre idolâtrie obscène pour l’innovation et la jeunesse.
Nous ne prions plus à l’autel du caractère,
de la gentillesse,
mais à celui de l’innovation et de ceux qui créent des bénéfices.
Amazon est devenu si puissant sur le marché
qu’il peut endommager d’autres industries,
rien qu’en les regardants, comme le Jedi.
Nike annonce qu’il vend sur Amazon : l'action monte
et celles de toutes les autres marques chutent.
Quand l’action Amazon monte, celle des autres détaillants chute
car les marchés assument que ce qui est bon pour Amazon nuit aux autres.
Ils ont réduit le prix du saumon de 33% en acquérant Whole Foods.
Entretemps, ils ont annoncé l’acquisition de Whole Foods,
et quand ils l'ont conclue,
Kroger, le plus grand épicier des États-Unis,
a perdu un tiers de sa valeur,
car Amazon venait d'acquérir un épicier onze fois plus petit que Kroger.
J’ai eu de la chance.
J’avais prédit l’acquisition de Whole Foods par Amazon,
la semaine précédant l'annonce.
Me voici, en train de me vanter, en public, dans les médias.
C’était la plus grosse acquisition de leur histoire.
C'était leur première opération dépassant un milliard.
On m'a demandé : « Comment as-tu fait ? »
Je vais partager ce secret avec vous.
Comment l’ai-je su ?
Je vais vous le dire.
J’avais aboyé à Alexa toute la journée
en essayant de comprendre ce qui se passait.
Scott Galleway : Alexa achète du lait entier.
Alexa : Je n’ai rien trouvé pour lait entier.
Alors, j’ajoute le lait entier à ta liste de courses.
Puis je lui demande :
Alexa, achète de la nourriture biologique.
A : La recherche pour produits biologiques donne
aliments pour bébé de Plum Organics, bananes et citrouilles.
12 sachets de 4 grammes.
Ça fait 15 dollars au total.
Voulez-vous les acheter ? »
Et comme ça arrive à mon grand âge,
j’étais confus.
SG : Alexa, achète de la nourriture complète [whole food]
A : J’ai acheté les options de Whole Foods Incorporated
à 42 dollars l’action.
J’ai facturé 13,7 milliards de dollars sur votre carte American Express. »
(Rires)
J’ai pensé que ce serait plus drôle.
On a personnifié ces sociétés,
et comme quand on est en colère contre les futilités commises par autrui
dans notre vie et nos relations, on doit se demander ceci :
« Qu’est-ce qui se passe ici ? Pourquoi la technologie nous déçoit-elle ? »
Je crois que le ratio de 1% de poursuite des dividendes,
et 99% de la recherche du progrès humain, s’est inversé.
Et on est entièrement focalisé sur les dividendes aux dépends de l’humain.
100 000 personnes se sont jointes au projet Manhattan
et ont littéralement sauvé le monde.
La technologie a sauvé le monde.
Ma mère était une juive de 4 ans vivant à Londres au début de la guerre.
Si nous n’avions pas gagné la course de la fission de l’atome,
aurait-elle survécu ?
C’est peu probable.
25 ans plus tard,
l’accomplissement le plus impressionnant de l’histoire de l’humanité
a posé un homme sur la Lune.
430 000 Canadiens, Anglais et Américains se sont réunis
autour d’une technologie très basique
et ont posé un homme sur la Lune.
Maintenant, nous avons les 700 000 des meilleurs et plus brillants scientifiques
des quatre coins du monde.
Ils jouent avec des lasers
alors que leurs prédécesseurs avaient des lance-pierres ou des pistolets à eau.
Ils ont le PIB indien avec lequel travailler.
Et, après avoir étudié ces sociétés pendant 10 ans,
je connais leur mission.
S’agit-il d’organiser l’information mondiale ?
S’agit-il de nous connecter ?
S’agit-il de créer plus de courtoisie humaine ?
Non.
Je sais pourquoi on les a rassemblés.
Je sais que pour la plus grande communauté de capital intellectuel et créatif,
la seule mission est de nous vendre une autre foutue Nissan.
Je m'appelle Scott Galloway, j’enseigne à NYU. Merci pour votre temps.
(Applaudissements)
Chris Anderson : Ce n’était pas prévu
mais tu viens de m'inspirer des questions, Scott.
(Rires)
C’était une diatribe pour le moins spectaculaire.
SG : Est-ce comme Letterman ?
Quand tu es bon, Il t'invite sur son canapé ?
CA : Non, non, on va aller au cœur de la conversation maintenant.
Tout le monde sait qu'après des années à vénérer la Silicon Valley,
le vent a soudain tourné de manière considérable.
Pour certains, c'est comme si on retournait le couteau dans la plaie,
ou qu'on donnait une raclée à des enfants qui viennent de se faire écharper.
Ne ressentez-vous aucune empathie pour eux ?
SG : Non, aucune.
Écoutez, voilà le problème :
ce n'est pas de leur faute, c'est de la nôtre.
Ce sont des entreprises ; leur but est de faire du profit.
Elles s'en fichent de notre âme.
Elles ne vont pas s'occuper de nous quand on sera vieux.
On a construit une société qui privilégie la valeur actionnariale,
et elles font ce qu'elles doivent faire.
Mais on doit élire des gens.
On doit s'obliger à les obliger
à accepter le même contrôle
que celui appliqué au reste de l'économie, point.
CA : Il y a une autre théorie,
plutôt en phase avec les faits,
qui dit que la plupart des dirigeants sont mus par de bonnes intentions,
pas forcément tout le monde,
mais la plupart des employés.
On connaît tous des gens qui travaillent dans ces entreprises,
et ils sont toujours tous convaincants à propos de leur mission qui est -
en fait, la théorie alternative,
c'est qu'il y a des conséquences imprévues,
que les technologies que nous déchaînons,
que les algorithmes avec lesquels on tente de personnaliser Internet, par exemple,
ont d'abord, des effets étranges, comme les bulles de filtres,
auxquels personne ne s'attendait.
Ensuite, elles se sont rendues vulnérables à des choses bizarres,
au hasard, des hackers russes qui créent des comptes
et font des choses auxquelles on ne s'attendait pas.
Dans un tel cas, la conséquence imprévue n'est pas envisageable ?
SG : Je ne pense pas...
Je suis presque sûr, statistiquement,
qu'ils ne sont pas moins biens ou meilleurs
que n'importe quelle société de 100 000 personnes.
Je ne pense pas qu'ils soient peu scrupuleux.
Au contraire, je dirais qu'il y a beaucoup de dirigeants civiques respectables.
Mais voici le problème :
lorsqu'on contrôle 90% de parts du marché,
ce qui représente davantage que le marché de la pub de n'importe quelle nation,
que vous êtes payé pour augmenter cette part de marché,
ce qui garantit votre sécurité économique,
et celle des familles de vos employés aussi,
il est impossible de s'empêcher d'exploiter le pouvoir à disposition.
C'est la base pour toute réglementation,
c'est la base de l'évidence universelle
que le pouvoir corrompt.
Il n'y a pas de mauvaises personnes ;
on leur a simplement permis de dépasser les limites.
CA : Alors votre argument n'est-il pas un peu exagéré ?
Je connais un peu --
Larry Page, par exemple, Jeff Bezos --
et je ne pense pas qu'ils se réveillent en se disant :
« Je dois vendre ces foutues Nissan. »
Je ne crois pas que ce soit leur motivation.
Je crois qu'ils essaient de construire quelque chose de cool,
et qu'ils sont certainement, dans leurs moments de réflexion,
aussi horrifiés que nous sur ce qui peut s'être produit.
Donc y a-t-il a une autre façon de recadrer ça,
dire par exemple que si le champ d'activités est la publicité,
il y a des dangers que l'on doit annoncer plus clairement ?
SG : Je pense qu'il est très difficile de créer des organisations comme on le fait,
de poursuivre la valeur actionnariale à tout prix.
Ce ne sont pas des ONG.
Les gens qui y travaillent le font pour assurer leur sécurité financière,
et celle de leur famille,
avant tout et par-dessus tout.
Quand on arrive à un point où on contrôle autant de pouvoir économique,
on utilise toutes les armes à disposition.
Tous ces gens ne sont pas mauvais.
Mais je pense que le rôle d'un gouvernement,
et le nôtre, en tant que consommateurs et électeurs,
est de nous assurer qu'un contrôle est exercé.
Nous leur avons donné une carte blanche ultime
parce qu'on les trouve fascinants.
CA : Voilà qui est dit clairement et avec éloquence !
Mark Zuckerberg, Jeff Bezos, Larry Page, Tim Cook, si vous nous écoutez,
nous vous invitons à venir présenter votre défense.
Merci beaucoup Scott.
SG : Merci à vous.
(Applaudissements)